hey what's up guys my name is the Cherno
welcome back to my c++ series today
we're going to be taking a look at loot
so as have loops I'm specifically
talking about for loops and while loops
to put it into simple terms moves are
basically things that we can write in
our code when we want to deform certain
operations multiple times so a really
simple example is what if we wanted to
print color world five times right would
we just copy and paste that line of code
five times or maybe put that code into a
function and then call that function
five times like literally five times in
our code should we do it that way
or can we just use a loop to say hey I
want this code here to run five times in
a row loops are also important kind of
for big picture stuff so picture a game
right if you've written a game odds are
you want to keep the game running right
you don't want to just like run the game
and render one frame and exit and that's
it right game done like one frame I
rented my frame I'm going to exit I'm
done now that would be very weird you
want to keep the game actually playing
and so for that what you need is
something called a game loop and a game
loop is just something that essentially
says hey like while the game is running
so while the user hasn't decided to quit
the game keep updating the game keep
rendering the game keep moving all the
characters around keep doing everything
like over and over again frame by frame
so it's a very important for programming
they used in like every program right
it's the same thing as like conditionals
which we talked about last week video up
here that kind of stuff right this is
much like that like you need to know
this stuff really well because you're
going to be using it as one of your
primary tools when you actually write
code when you write a program so first
of all let's start with fold it the
example that I gave earlier was printing
color world five times and again we
could achieve that just by copying and
pasting this log call five times and if
I run this code you're going to see that
we of course do get hello world printing
to the console five times however to
make our lives a little bit easier what
we can do is write a for loop for loop
to start with the keyword for and then
basically break up into three parts each
of these three parts are separated by a
semicolon the first part is a variable
declaration so usually you would declare
some sort of variable here so we are
going to write int I equals 0 now the
variable name being I is a little bit of
convention some say it says the iterator
which of course is relevant can because
we'll be iterating over this code you
can really call this variable absolutely
anything at all so doesn't have to be an
integer and it also doesn't have to be
equal to zero after I show you guys a
simple for loop we are going to break
the down a little bit and see what we
can do because bullets are actually
really really flexible and you can
really like make them do pretty much
anything you want the second part is a
condition basically this says that as
long as this condition is true I'm going
to keep executing code inside the for
loop so in this case since we want this
code to execute five times write this
log color world we want to call that
five times we're going to write AI is
less than five and I'll explain how this
ties in together in just a second the
last statement is basically code that
will be called before the next iteration
of the for loop so in this case what we
want to do is write AI plus plus which
basically is the same thing as saying I
plus equals one or I equals I plus one
which basically means that we're going
to increment our variable which starts
at zero of course here we're going to
increment it by one we're going to +1 it
every single iteration of this for loop
and then of course we provide a body
which is basically just saying that
anything in this body is the contents of
our forward so this is actually what's
going to be looped this is the closure
will be executed multiple times I say
multiple times but of course these
conditions are going to determine
whether this code is executed at all or
maybe once or it could be a hundred
times right it's all depending on this
condition let's go ahead and stick one
of our log calls into here and I'll get
rid of all of these extra one if we hit
our 5 to run our code you'll see we get
the same result five times hello world
ok cool let's break this down a little
bit this declaration is the first thing
that will happen when our instruction
pointer reaches this line of code here
it will first of all declare whatever is
written in here right from this case
we're creating a new variable called I
what it will then do is immediately
check to see if this condition is true
if this condition is true we're going to
go ahead and jump to the body of our for
loop and able to hear whatever is there
when we have finished executing the body
and we hit this curly bracket here this
closing one we're going to go back up to
here and perform whatever code is
written here so in this case were
incrementing
by one after that happens we're going to
go back to the condition and check to
see if the condition is true now of
course at this point I used to be zero
now we've been chromatid by one so now
we're checking if one is less than five
it is of course less than five so we're
going to jump back here and perform this
code it's going to keep going until
finally I will be equal to four we're
going to run this code jump up here
increment I by one which gives us five
and now looking pairing if five is less
than five however five is not less than
five because five is equal to five so
this condition is false which means we
now jump to line ten over here to
execute end gap and that in essence is
how that folders will actually run five
times now I just want to stress that
these three parts of this flawless
declaration are exactly what I said they
are right this is just code that will be
executed at the beginning of the for
loop once only this is a comparison upon
some kind of bullying that will be
evaluated before the next iteration of
the for loop and then this is some kind
of death looks like some kind of code
that will be executed at the end of our
for loop so what I could do is like
literally I could say actually in I
equals Iran we'll put that over here and
leave this completely blank just like
that right that's perfectly valid code I
could also say that this I plus plus I'm
actually just going to drop it here
right because it's that's going to have
the same result and if I run this even
though it looks a little bit weird we're
actually going to get the exact same
result because we haven't actually
changed the behavior code at all we've
just moved some things around similarly
I could write a bully in here called
like condition or something set it equal
to true and have that to be my actual
condition right so got my condition I'm
going to do I plus plus and then I might
do something like if I is not less than
five anymore
right I'm going to set condition equal
to false and if I run this code you can
see that I'm still going to get hello
world printed in five times because
again I haven't changed the behavior of
my program I've just rewritten the code
in a slightly different way but I'm
telling you all this so that you know
that for loops they can do anything
right like you don't have to always be
like fourteen i20 eyes worse than five
bucks plus that's boring right they can
contain any kind of sentence
want you can also of course call
functions in that like for loop setting
anything right the possibilities are
literally endless you can also get rid
of the condition entirely which
basically means that it's the same thing
as writing true right this will never be
false and if I run this it's actually
going to be an endless loop right it's
never going to end so if I hit f5 right
now to run this you'll see that we're
going to actually keep printing hello
world as our program keeps running until
we manually terminate it that's pretty
much it for for loops I mean they're
really really simple for doing like
running code multiple times for example
I want to print hello world five times
fantastic for that really easy to set up
for that also they're really useful with
arrays when you want to kind of go
through and array kind of linearly like
that as well very useful for that the
next thing that we'll move onto is wild
it so a while loop is much like a for
loop it's just that it doesn't have this
kind of statement at the beginning and
this payment at the end is just got a
condition
so basically tried a while loop will
write the keyword while and then inside
here we put some kind of condition so
for example I is less than five right
has an example and of course I would
declared up here so if we run this this
will basically perform whatever code is
in here as long as I is less than five
so if we were to rewrite our for loop
let me just bring back to follows to
what it was originally
if we if we wanted to basically
replicate this for loop in here we would
have to write into I equals 0 out here
and then do the I plus plus at the end
of the loop so over here right and then
right now what we have here is actually
exactly the same I'm just going to in
between these I'm just going to print
like a whole bunch of equal signs just
to separate be two statements but if I
run this you can see that we get the
same results from both loops right there
both printing hello world five times so
why use a while loop instead of a for
loop or like when would you use a for
loop instead of a while loop basically
it comes down to whether or not you need
a variable right because these loops are
identical you can use them
interchangeably right it's more a matter
of convention or a matter of style than
it is an actual card rule because again
like there's no actual difference
between the two loops they can do
exactly the same thing if you so want
want them to but the conventions are
basically if you have a certain can do
that already exists that you want to
just kind of compare so for example I
mentioned that whole game would example
where you had a variable called running
and you might want to kind of keep that
game loop going as long as that running
variable is true because running equals
true basically means that your program
is still running if you wanted to do
something like that I would probably use
a while loop because all we need is a
condition we don't need to be changing
the condition after every iteration we
don't need to declare the condition to
start off the loop it's already a
variable that we've got or a function
call that we can use and that's just
going to be completely like fine right
it's not something that we actually have
to keep kind of updating or set up
initially none of that stuff right
whereas if I wanted to go through an
array and the array had a certain size
for example my array with ten elements
long then I will use as follows because
first of all I want to run that code
exactly ten times so I want to keep
track of some kind of variable and only
run that loop ten times but also that
variable will be useful for accessing
elements inside that array because if I
want to access every element in a ten
element array I need some kind of offset
so that I can like an index so that I
can access an element in that array and
of course we're going to talk about
arrays in the future but that I variable
that we happen to be tracking and it's
going to go 0 1 2 3 4 5 as our
iterations go on is going to be
absolutely perfect for that so we've got
4 and we've got while but there is
actually one more loop that we have and
it's called a do-while loop now these
aren't that useful I don't personally
use these that often but they are there
and they do have some uses although
again you won't be seeing these anywhere
near as much as follows or while loops
so basically we rise to do keyword and
then we have a body and then at the end
we write while and we have some kind of
condition so for example again I'll just
do eyes less than 5 the only difference
between the do-while loop and a while
loop is that this body will be executed
at least once no matter what right so
for example if we if we change this into
I situation so that instead we actually
just have a condition and it might be
equal to solve if I stick that condition
in here this while is actually going to
function much like an if statement in a
sense that if this is false well then
it's never going to run the code in here
however a do-while loop even
this is false right if it is such a
condition conditioners fault it will
function as if it's not a loop it's
going to run the code here one it's
going to come down to the wire look at
the condition are the conditions false
so I'm not going to loop and that's
pretty much it that's how do while loops
work alright so that's pretty much it
for today's video
hope you guys enjoy very basic
introduction to loops we're going to be
using these a lot throughout the series
they're used in like pretty much every
algorithm you can think of loops are
extremely useful when we talk about our
arrays we'll be talking about how we can
use foliage to access arrays and all
that stuff so everything will tie in
nicely I'm going to do a more in-depth
look at them sometime in the future
where we're actually going to look at
the disassembly and look at the actual
CPU instructions that get generated for
loops and take a bit of a deeper look I
just didn't want to make this video too
complicated so the link to that in depth
video will be somewhere in the
description when that video actually
comes out I hope you guys enjoy this
video if you did please hit that like
button you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram and if you really like this
series and you want to see more episodes
and you want to support the series you
can support me on patreon back home for
slash the show now and I will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]